Hello Freak bitches.
Like I didn't smoke blunts until I
hung out with Charlie Murphy. Really?
Charlie used to smoke legit blunts.
Like he had his cousin rich who had
rolled these legit blondes out of like
Swisher sweets.
Take out the tobacco,
leave like a little bit in and then roll
it up with weed and then lick it down
and we would get home.
Yeah, nervous. Hi. Terrifying high.
He was one of the hardest deaths that
I ever had to deal with. Really? Yeah,
because I wish I contacted him more.
I wish we got together more,
but we were always on the road. You
know that guy's a man. Like he was a,
he was a real man, like, like,
like he never had any like weird
shit yet a work through. He was,
he always held his mud.
Like Charlie was different man.
He was like a guy who didn't come into
celebrity at all until his forties so was
developed.
He was a real man that's loves that guide.
So it's one of those guys
like sometimes you get tired,
you get tired,
you're just doing too many things and
you've for forget to concentrate on people
that you've run into in your
life that you're like, God damn,
that guy was a good dude. Like Charlie
Murphy was a good motherfucker.
Like he had a joke on stage that
talked about it wasn't trying to,
but he was like, he goes,
people say to me, you know
that people yell out Chai Man.
Hey John and Matt, hey. He goes,
hey man said, have a bother you.
It's just yells out Charlie Murphy.
Every time he seen he goes, no.
He goes, because for the first
time in my life it was like,
hey you Eddie Murphy's brother.
Right? Anybody laugh about it onstage,
like slap as ne and like
that was real for him. Sure.
We got to experience a guy who like went
through a whole life as a grown man and
was approaching middle age
before fame kicked in wild man.
He only had like a 10 15
year ride before he died.
Yeah. Was a good dude, man. The
magnitude of like, you know that show,
but like particularly like two sketches,
like that's how big an impact.
Those two sketches,
they would just play that I
remember when he started a tour,
you know when you go to the
clubs they play it before. Oh,
just that like of the teaser that he's
coming coming next week or two weeks from
now.
It would be just like a little bit of
like the Rick James Sketch or the print
separate and fucking all
the shows be styled. Man.
You know what man, he didn't, man,
I really feel like there's a developmental
process that you can apply to like
UFC fighters and even stand up comedians.
If you take a guy who's
got some potential,
then you make them fight Anderson Silva
in his prime when he's 20 years old and
he gets knocked unconscious, he's
never going to be the same again. Yeah.
And I almost feel like this is
the same thing with comedians.
I don't care if you're 40 or 50 or 60
or 20 to go onstage and eat is horrific.
Yeah.
And what Charlie did was he went from
being a guy who was on the supple show to
hosting a show with other
comedians like Darnell. Yeah.
And a and Dave and whoever was on the
show and talking a little like, Hey,
what's up?
And instead of just continuing to do that,
he started headlining cause that where
the money, that's where the money was. No,
no up and Mike famous.
So bringer shows. No, no
dude, we did 22 dates together,
22 days together and we swapped.
Who went back and forth? Like he headlined
one. I had one, one, he and mine one,
I headlined one and he just fucked
member. Those Doug, his seat.
Who have either when you were on, well I
swapped, but I did three. I did Irvine,
San Diego, and Phoenix. And so damn,
you did three different
people in different nights.
But I saw, yeah, I saw him.
I saw him struggle when I
must've been rough. Oh my God.
And then I saw him actually do really
well the next night. Really? Yeah. Yeah.
Well if he can get on the middle spot,
he could do pretty good.
He was a funny dude, but it's
just not, it's not a good number.
It's not the right place to put
some money. His mega millions joke.
Do you remember he was doing that?
You had a bunch of great jokes.
He had a bunch of gay jokes. Man.
He was a funny and and offstage,
maybe one of the funniest guys of all
time. He took me to dinner on that thing,
which I didn't expect and I don't
think rich wanted me to come and,
and like we went out to dinner and he
was, yeah, no, no, no. He, his cousin,
his cousin. But he was as, he
was like, what you like that
show was fresh. That was,
you know, and like he, he
was telling stories. He was,
he told the story that I texted you
to ask him when you had them on.
I go ask him if he could let
go if Johnny guilt. Yeah,
cause it fucking Mike Tyson
Tiger story. Yeah. Oh,
that's what you're going to story.
Pet Tiger.
No one want to get out of
the limousine. Yeah. So
crazy though. Did you ever
hear the busboys story? Which
ones? That Charlie Murphy.
When is Eddie let him borrow clothes?
No. Oh my God. That's so funny.
That's so funny. I'll never do it justice.
And it's so good when he tells it. No,
you got to tell it.
You got to tell it cause then I can sit
available online so you gotta find it.
So see if you can find,
you know,
you're never gonna be able to find it
cause it's in snoop Dogg's podcast. Oh,
all right. Oh I bet. I bet someone's put
it on Youtube. I know Bert Kreischer did.
I fucking grabbed it the day he died.
And I was like,
this is one of the best stories I've
ever, that's right. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's where I saw it. Yeah. But I don't
know how I put it online. But anyway,
to make,
he gets,
he comes out of the navy and he comes out
to La and then they all want to go out
to a party. But all these guys,
navy clothes, he's just out and ed,
he's the biggest fucking movie star on
earth. Right. So his brother is like,
and it's young primetime.
Oh is this it? Yeah.
Oh, just play this place.
Give me some shit high.
When Eddie had to
fly outfits,
did you ever like take that away?
Oh Man. You know what he did
like Nigga, take my shit off.
One of the most brutal,
brutal experiences, outfits.
I first got out the navy, I came out
to La and my brother was huge, right?
So we hanging out at different tables.
He had, you know, show business clothing.
He was supposed to have it. No, he was
just showman. Everybody knew he was.
So he happened to own a glitter busboy.
Jack up from the boys are back in town.
Bus Boy Jack.
And we was going out to the,
it was a century 21 over there.
Then there was a club over. He said,
Yo man, you want to wear this jacket?
So the jacket was a green
glitter busboys Jack.
I'm trying to get my stamp coming out
of the navy. All I had was uniform.
I put the busboy jacking or
they had my chains and all that.
And then we went to the club and I thought
I was coming and walking through the
club and I hear everybody go, yeah,
Mrs Eddie Murphy from New York
who's up behind the group that
they could do, which I don't know,
it looked like [inaudible].
I was like, Yo man, the,
and started burning gas,
sit down with somebody, just poured
kerosene on, executive lit this shit up.
Ah,
do you know when he died?
I used to enjoy and I knew this would
be a Tom cause you guys a tour with him.
He was like, you don't know how funny is
he thought he could fight Billy Gill? No,
he said that Johnny Gill, Johnny Gill,
we're looking at the screen and his ass.
He's like, you think Oscar de la Hoya
could fuck you up? And I was like, yeah.
He's like, I know. Right? And I was
like, yeah man, he's a professional.
He would ruin your life. And he was like,
Johnny Gill thinks he could fuck him up.
I was like,
what?
And then he started telling a story
about how he was hanging out with Johnny
Gill and Johnny Gill just
looked at TV and was like,
I could fuck up to Oscar de la Hoya.
And he was like,
what are you talking about man?
In the way that child, he's like,
Oscar de Hilbert Bray rearrange
the whole way. You Shit. Look man.
And, and Johnny gale was like, no, he's
pretty. He's like, that don't mean shit.
Punch a hole in your face.
Charlie Charlie Murphy was at dinner
with Maury Smith who is a former UFC
heavyweight champion of the world.
I haven't salivary who's a former UFC
fighter who actually had a move that we
started crying the salivary.
Remember Ivan?
Ivan had a move where it was
what wasn't really his mood,
but it was a move that he was one of
the first guys to tap somebody with it
where he got the triangle from the back
and elevated his hips to like press down
on your back. Guys were tapping out
from like getting triangled from behind.
We started realizing like how dangerous
that movie, so I haven't salivary,
it's like a time tested warrior,
right? So Maurice Smith,
former heavyweight champion Ivan salivary,
Charlie Murphy is explaining why y'all
Niggas don't know about the Chicago Ridge.
Hey,
please explain.
And some particular
like martial arts move.
It's called the rich hand and it's a
strike and I don't know what the Chicago
rich hand was,
but Charles was insistent that no one
was trying out the Chicago Ridge hand in
MMA and that people could do it.
And like they were laughing and Charlie
was like, no, fuck you. He goes,
you tell me. I don't, I don't hit
you in the head with a rich hand.
Red Ban took a picture and I put
it up on my Instagram. I find it.
It's Charlie Murphy standing up.
How are e Smith and the Ivan Salad
right now like this? Like Ah,
Charlie's got his hand up at this time.
Roddy chopping something on the bridge.
They notes. I'll hit you on the
bridge. He, oh no, dude, we were,
we were, it's like fancy fucking Ruth's
Chris Steak House somewhere. Yeah.
Cry.
Charlie Murphy was crushing like
that's a natural thing on the,
I mean like I look at him
and I go just him. Yeah.
How much fun would it have been the
first time you were sitting on those ship
else? That and he showed
any told that uh, that's it.
That's it. That's the photo. That
guy in the right hand corner is my,
is Marvin Sapp. That's Ivan salivary and
bright to his left. Her Charlie Murphy's.
Right? Go for the black
guy. That's Maury Smith.
That's Maurice for that is the former
UFC heavyweight champion of the world.
That's trolley talking about standing up.
Look how wide his eyes are.
Look at the smile underneath his left arm.
Look at that guy laugh.
Everybody said yes. Hi. I'm
wish I was in this photo,
but I was crying too, but I was probably
under the table at this point. Like
I did that podcast with Joe.
It was like the same sort of situation
I said under the table crying at that
point. Like, I love you guys, but I
got to head out. We're all going to go.
This is the point. Like Ralphy
like Charlie, like everybody,
we're all going to go.
You know, the quicker you realize that,
the quicker you get that in your head,
the more you'll enjoy this
weird time we're in the
sunshine right after the rain.
It doesn't last. It's a good time to
be a comic. It's good time to be alive.
But is it the human race as a
person? All of us, there's no,
no one gets out alive. No.
One quicker. We remember that.
The better. We're all be not work.
Okay.